a lot of people consider mini golf to be
very benign and all fun and games but at
this level it can be a cutthroat
competition among the greatest players
in the world
[Music]
my name is matt male i'm a professional
mini golfer
[Music]
i was a regular golfer ever since
childhood i started at about eight years
old and putting was always the greatest
facet of my game the idea of doing
nothing but putting for 18 holes
instantly appealed to me and i just
began practicing a lot
people don't realize that mini golf is a
highly precise sport
improvement can come
very tediously
to be competitive it really requires
an extensive
mapping of each hole
and we can be out here for up to 10
hours a day or so for several days
before a tournament
when i first arrive at a course
i diagnose the holes
i want to come up with a clear plan of
attack on each hole and then just it's a
matter of repetition from there
[Music]
we are at the 2016 mini golf masters in
north myrtle beach south carolina this
tournament is the premier event each
year in mini golf
it draws players from all over the world
the green jacket is the most coveted
prize in mini golf
the competition is very fierce the
players here are the best of the best
and it's an immense challenge because
even a stretch of five bad minutes or
ten bad minutes can disqualify you from
contention
just a tiny miscue here or there can
spell major disaster on one hole
i really do have an authentic admiration
of what the winner had to do to to
perform
under the pressure of such a major
tournament because
i i know from experience how hard it is
mini golf's not a sport for everyone
there's constant frustration there's
constant adversity it
it rewards patience and it rewards
determination
and it never gets old to see the ball go
in the hole
i don't think that thrill will ever go
away
you